diálogo amistoso y constructivo según La
diplomacia alemana la reunión entre el
concierto alemán olabsols y el
presidente francés Emmanuel macun en el
Palacio del Eliseo se preveía tensa Este
miércoles con el telón de fondo los
desacuerdos en materia de armas y
energía el objetivo de este intercambio
era relanzar la cooperación Franco
alemana que atraviesa un momento tenso
tenemos la intención de mantener vivo
este motor Franco alemán cuando las
prioridades de un país no son
necesariamente No convergen
necesariamente con las prioridades del
otro entonces la fuerza de la alianza
Franco alemana es que siempre somos
capaz de ponernos de acuerdo y empujar a
toda Europa hacia arriba existen muchos
desacuerdos entre las dos potencias
europeas las opiniones difieren en
cuestiones energéticas y a que Berlín se
opone a un tope en los precios del gas
en Europa que París defiende Francia
también se molestó Por una medida
adoptada por la sol sin consultar un
escudo tarifario de 200 mil millones de
euros para los precios de la energía con
el fin de ayudar a los hogares alemanes
Por último el armamento también fue
objeto de discordia con su presupuesto
de 100 mil millones de euros Alemania
favorece la compra de equipos
estadounidenses en detrimento de la
industria Europea y además lanzó un
proyecto de defensa antiaérea con
Estados Unidos e Israel estos fueron los
temas de las conversaciones entre los
dos líderes aunque no se hizo ningún
anuncio oficial tras su reunión los dos
hombres acordaron a volver a reunirse
antes de principios de noviembre y del
viaje de olabsols a chino